under item one
apologies for absence
we've received apologies from councillor
dre
we also have apologies for
councillor phil shaw
and darling gadsden
are there any others
right agenda item 2 substitute members
members councillor arthur williams will
be substituting for councillor dre
councillor mike carter will be
substitute for councillor phil shaw
and councillor mike webb
will be substituting for ireland gadsden
i'd like to say at this stage thank you
for all those that um are substituting
this is a very very important meeting
audit is is important to the council so
those that have
put their names forward to to substitute
thank you very much and for everybody
attending too
we don't have a vice chairman tonight
but
i'm going to proceed without one
agenda item 3 non-members attending
there are none
agenda item 4
minutes of the meeting held on the 15th
of december 2021
are the minutes agreed members
agenda item 5
to receive declarations of interest
are there any declarations of interest
members
agenda item six
internal audit annual audit plan
2022-2023
the chief auditor mike porter will
present this report
thank you
thank you chair um
the report presents the proposed audit
plan for
2022-23
the audit plan itself is essentially a
programmer work for the year ahead and
sets out all the audits we're going to
complete during that financial year
the audit plan enables myself
the purpose of the um the audio plan is
to set out a program of work and that
work is designed to enable me at year
end to provide an opinion on the
council's arrangements for governance
risk management internal control
so we we complete all that work and that
namely enables myself to draw together
that opinion near end
the opinion is important because it
feeds into the annual government
statement
so in putting together the the audio
plan itself um we consult
on senior managers in terms of actually
what they like to see in the audit plan
we we look at the council's risk
registers what risks are there in the
risk registers
we also consult with other local
authorities in terms of what might be in
their audit plan
we do horizon scanning in terms of what
is important to internal audit
a couple of the major topics that people
talk about at the moment is cyber
security that's high top of people's
agenda
climate change is another area that
people suggest that warren's looking at
in terms of the council's arrangement
for dealing with climate change and
becoming carbon neutral by 2030 so these
are the things we consider in putting
together the the audit plan
um
appendix a sets out the audits we're
going to complete um and they're in
relation to the corporate risks for the
authority
um we also
put a proposed outline scope gives you
gives you a flavor in terms of what it
will be about
um
also
what we would normally bring to this
community along with the audit plan
is the audit charter the the audit
charter itself is essentially a terms of
reference for internal audit it sets out
the scope and responsibility how we will
deliver internal audit
um
there's likely to be some proposed
changes to the way internal wood is
delivered and in 2023 and i'll pass on
to naomi to talk about our plans or
aspirations for internal audit delivery
in the following year
yeah thank you um
yeah just for audit committees noting um
really um
you may have already seen on the key
decisions document um but there is a
proposal from next year that
as well as the actual chief audit
executive role um being delivered by
bazidan by a council
um obviously being fulfilled by mike at
the moment that actually the whole
internal audit function is actually
delivered via basildon
borough council
and that's mainly being prompted by the
fact that jim's due to retire in a few
months
so we've obviously had to look at
options in terms how we deliver the
service going forward
we have looked at a range of options
um but i think most members as i
mentioned before will be aware that
there's
quite a challenging market to recruit
good internal auditors
and added to that we know that as a very
small authority we've got limited
resilience to actually deliver the audit
plan um we're reliant on a couple of key
individuals um so we do feel at this
stage that it is
the best
solution for the council and will
deliver the best value for money um if
there's a kind of a joint-terrain
partnership arrangement with um
basildon to deliver those services um
because they'll have a bigger team more
resilience more capacity
more training opportunities etc so the
the portfolio holder decision hasn't
actually been um taken as such yet but
it's due to be taken within the next
couple of weeks um and likewise based on
council we've got paper that they're
taking to their council to approve
um
i just wanted i think i just wanted to
mention as obviously this might be a
question about why we're sort of um
linking with bowser and at this time as
opposed to brentwood when we've got um a
shared service arrangement obviously
coming on stream
with brentwood
um the main reason for that is really um
just about the um
sort of um
procurement processes in place for
brentwood they actually have their
internal audit services delivered by an
external firm so they're not in a
position to sort of move forward with us
um in terms of internal audit services
at this point however it is something we
may consider again in the future but
obviously as i said we've got this
pre-existing relationship with basildorn
um and they are in a position to be able
to deliver those for us without um you
know um to give a kind of seamless
transition so um at this point it does
feel like that that's the best way to
deliver the services from 2223 onwards
but yeah really just
for committees noting because it's not
actually a decision of yours to make but
i just want you to be aware of that
because obviously it will impact on in
terms of how we deliver the audit plan
for next year
can i just ask a quick question is some
mike porter still going to be
doing um our some of our internal audit
um yeah so uh mike's um we'll still be
in post and we'll still deliver the
chief audit executive role um obviously
we're contracting what if you like with
bowser
as an entity so obviously we can't
guarantee that personnel would say the
same but obviously i don't think there's
any intention for mike to
step out of that role at the moment so
um there will be a continuity from that
point of view and also
under the arrangement and it's expected
that the other auditor role would um
transfer across so again we'd have
continuity in terms of the actual audit
resource um
that delivers the audits um yeah being
the same person that does that at the
moment but obviously they'll have the
sort of backup and resilience from the
rest of the baseline team as well thank
you because i think that's important
councillor
he's there good to hear
thank you chairman um congratulations on
your retirement mike
no i was jason
congratulations i'll retire you off as
well
and thank you naomi you did actually
answer one of my questions i was going
to ask why we're going that way looking
at the appendix a
um
you've got corporate risk
two which is a good assessment
then you go three a3b et cetera down and
they're assessed as adequate can we not
bring them up to um good assessment
that's on 6.6 page
um
might
right this is um go to page 6.6 on
appendix a
go to corporate risk 2 it says good
assessment go to corporate risk three a
three b and four and i think there is
okay and it says ancestors adequate i
just wondered if they could be
is there any reason we can't get the
most um good assessment um
yeah so um i i can transfer the
microphone back but um essentially yeah
so this the the the appendix as mike
says how is um the um sets out all the
corporate risk areas and whether there
is an audit plan for next year against
those
on the number of them there is
audits planned to be delivered and in
that case as a short explanation of what
those audits are however some of the
risks say none planned for next year so
for example with corporate risk two
there's a failure of safeguarding
arrangements it says none planned and
likewise for 3a
in those instances it just gives a
synopsis of the assessment that was made
in prior years so
where you refer to good assessment that
was for safeguarding in
2021 when it was last audited
and in terms of food inspections that
was last audited in 1920 when it's
assessed as adequate but neither of
those are actually on the audit plan for
next year um because obviously
we can't audit every area every year so
it's done on a kind of cyclical basis
but obviously just to take your sort
more general point um
it's the role of internal audit to kind
of assess
the control environment for each of
these individual areas as an
organization as a council
we obviously strive to improve
performance and the audit process
informs that in terms of looking at
areas where there are
recommendations that could be made to
bring up performance but it's obviously
not the responsibility of audit as a
function to bring that performance up
it's the responsibility of the council
as a whole and the audit the auditor's
responsibility is then just to make that
assessment of where they think they're
at so i would yeah so there is obviously
an intent to bring up performance an
audit can help in that but it's not
actually audit's responsibility to bring
up
performance
yes
for the explanation so i take all the
portfolios for these areas know that um
when they were altered they were just
assessed as adequate
yes all it is
they've got to get their people involved
to make the a better
organization
because i think food
health and safety these are very
relevant items that we need to have
i think that should be very good on some
of them i mean i would like to go into
full uh food premises and find it's just
um assessed as adequate so i just
wondered if the portfolios were going to
be made aware that they need to get
their teams
out there and get and get their work
sorted a little bit better thank you
um if i may respond
um so just to um give an idea of the
levels of um adequacy so um i know
adequate doesn't sound um great on
principle but the top level is good so
that's the highest level then is
adequate and then what's it poor um
sorry um the two beneath that
anyway limited sorry yes forget the
terminology um so yeah adequate it
basically means that there are as it
suggests adequate controls in place
which you know you could argue is um
good enough obviously we want um areas
to have good but to sort of address your
wider point again in terms of portfolio
holders being aware um
yes so all of these audits where we
refer to prior year audits have been
both brought to this committee so
members of the audit committee will have
seen the detailed report that jim and
mike are prepared and all the
recommendations associated with that
and as a matter of course when an audit
is completed the portfolio holder is
copied in as well as the assistant
director obviously so there is an
awareness and and obviously one of the
key um ways we hold people to account is
through the recommendations and
monitoring of the implementation of
those which again comes back to this
committee for them to consider
thank you
any further questions
no
members
there is one recommendation set out at
paragraph 8.1 on page 6.5 of the report
that the proposed audit plan and charter
for
2022-23 be approved
can those members in favor please raise
their hands
that's unanimous
members thank you
item number seven
audit progress report 2021-22
the chief auditor mike porter will
present this report
thank you
um just before i move on to against your
7 i'd like to say a big thank you to jim
for the past four or five years that
i've worked with him he's made my life
relatively easy
um so a big thanks to jim for the last
four or five years that i've worked for
him
as i say it's been a pleasure working
with him
right thank you um
moving on to agenda item seven so this
is a progress report to update members
on the work of the internal audit team
since the last committee back in
december
so since i reported to this committee
back in december we've completed the
further five audit engagements
two of these engagements are rated is
good so that's the top level
and three were assessed as adequate so
there's nothing of
concern that i need to bring to your
attention if if i had given a limited
assurance rating then i would basically
talk you through those audits and and
raise with you the concerns identified
but as both as all those audits have
been assessed as either good or adequate
there's nothing that is concerning me
that i need to bring to your attention
in terms of counter fraud activity
the activities undertaken by the senior
compliance officer that sits in revs and
bends and
as part of the work he undertakes he
looks at fraud in relation to council
tax business rates and as part of the
work he he generates cashable savings
where he identifies unbuilt properties
and as you can see from the report he
continues to make good progress in
returning significant cashable savings
to the local authority
lastly i'd like to talk about progress
made by service departments in
addressing internal audit
recommendations and this is identified
at section 3.
um
we've raised a total of two new
recommendations since the last audit
committee in
december okay
um
we have a total of um
12 live live recommendations as it
stands so there's only a few order
recommendations currently live there's
not a large number outstanding
recommendations
four of the live recommendations we
currently have the dates have been
pushed back
for a number of reasons and i'll pass
the gym to talk about those four
recommendations where the dates have
been moved
draw your attention please to page 7.21
uh the procurement audit um
members will recall that this was linked
into a constitution review
but this this whole position uh
regarding the constitution it will is
likely to be sort of reset with a
harmonization to certain aspects with
brentwood council
and accordingly uh
the date has been reset to consider to
develop a process and to get that into
place by the end of the year
on page seven point two three and two
four on budget setting the same
principle applies
on page 7.25 relating to complaints
this work has been completed and a
revised procedure has been drafted it
just now waits signed off by the
leadership team so but the next
committee i expect that to be reported
as completed
on page 7.26 housing benefits
this was a low priority action to update
an internal control which staff complete
declaration that they will not uh
access the revenues of benefit system
for their own or friends or families
since the recommendation this has become
linked with a requirement by the dwp
for all those who will have access to
the revenues and benefits system to have
a basic dbs check
that process has been completed and
we're going to roll out the
declaration but obviously
given the time of the year a priority
has been given to implementing the new
council tax support scheme
and for the annual billing for council
tax and business rate
and again i expect this to be completed
by the end of april
and if i could just draw your attention
to
the
cemetery management recommendation on
page 7.25
we didn't have an update on the status
of this at the time of finalizing the
report but i can now confirm that this
recommendation has been implemented
thank you
thank you
members are there any questions
no
members there are three recommendations
set out at paragraph 7.1 on page 7.2 of
the report
one that the update on delivering the
2021-22 audit plan be noted
two that the conclusions and results
from the completed audit engagements in
appendices 2 be noted
and three that the updated status of
audit recommendations in appendix 3 be
noted
are these noted members
right before i close the meeting i would
also like to add my thanks
to um jimmy cavani he's been very very
helpful very thorough very clear with
your explanations at meetings and you
will be very well missed
but at least we won't be having any
phone alarms going off in another
meeting
i've got to go out with a bank so
so thank you for me and i'm sure from
all of us thank you thank you for your
help
so members uh and
the subs for tonight thank you very much
that's the final gender item and the
meeting is closed at
7
49
750
thank you